what up space fam golson here from anime
up we're back at it again with another
crazy boruto chapter
you guys have been loving the naruto and
boruto videos on this channel and to
keep them coming you know what to do
smash that like button and share this
video with any cultured ninja that you
know
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select all or you will miss
future naruto and boruto videos
and while you wait for the next chapter
to drop feel free to check out my
growing naruto playlist where you'll
find videos about the hokage utumaki
clan
otsusuki clan and much more link in the
description
and leave any suggestions for future
naruto and boruto videos you would like
me to cover
in the comments now without further ado
let's jump into it spoilers and all
the colored image at the front of this
one is naruto looking epic
my favorite image in a while you can see
he's serious and ready to get down to
business
this is chapter 50 so a pretty big one
and it did not disappoint
it's called potential value and we shall
see the significance of that as we move
forward
remember that last chapter everything
was set up perfectly
for the fight to get underway boruto
teleported them to a dragon ball esque
fighting environment
where they could cause as much damage as
they want without hurting any bystanders
and speaking of dragon ball check out my
brand new podcast called the dragon ball
virgin where i discuss the entire series
from start to finish
with my one friend who's never watched
anime before i'll link it in the
description and if you somehow haven't
watched dragon ball yet
you can watch along with us or if you
have you can just relive the glory of
the famous shonen anime with us
but shameless plug aside boruto did a
great job here the conditions are ideal
now
for our guys to go all out in the most
epic fight of boruto yet naruto is not
super happy with seeing his son getting
involved which is understandable
and he's wondering where they are but
borto doesn't know
he just acted before thinking it through
too much he knew otsutsuki
should be able to go to another
dimension so he figured he could do that
using his karma
luckily the gamble paid off and it shows
how quickly borto is growing before our
eyes as a fighter
naruto is worried but acknowledges that
boruto is just like he used to be
acting first in thinking later and
depending on the circumstances you gotta
act and overthinking can be a killer so
in this case it's not necessarily a bad
trait to have
sometimes you don't have time to
overthink and you just gotta follow your
instincts
and boruto just saved potentially a lot
of people by doing so
ishiki is not down to wait and begins
his attack
enough of tok no jutsu he thinks let's
get this over with he goes for boruto
and
naruto tries to stop him but ishiki is
just so
quick before naruto can even get to
boruto
ishiki is leagues above them in the air
holding boruto by his throat
we're dealing with a crazy power gap
right here and the story is trying to
make that blatantly clear
we get more bad but also exciting news
ishiki tells us that as momoshiki's
vessel
boruto has progressed further than
ishiki thought i like how he uses the
word
otutsuki vacation which is pretty
hilarious
but anyways the point is boruto is
already at 70 or even 80
complete as a vessel so it's a
double-edged sword yes he's potentially
gonna be completely taken over by
momoshiki
which i expect won't actually happen or
at least in the way that ishiki thinks
but it also means that boruto is
potentially getting much stronger
in the ototoki video i made i explained
that the ototouch are the strongest clan
and they are portrayed as godlike the
further borto gets in his ototoki
vacation
the more godlike power he should be able
to access
so i know that him being further along
in the process is not necessarily good
news
but i am hyped to see his power progress
and ishiki
actually shares a similar sentiment
asking borto about how much power is
hiding within him he wants boruto to
show him all of his hidden power
and for once ishiki and i can agree on
something but
before we get to see ultra instinct
boruto sasuke uses his powers to switch
their positions
boruto is now safe but coughing and
sasuke is in the heat of it with ishiki
the chidori fan favorite move that was
at one point the most epic thing that
we've ever seen
is nothing to ishiki he stops sasuke's
arm
and calmly notes that he's in the way
ishiki looks annoyed while sasuke is
straight up sweating
and my congrats to both naruto and
sasuke for trying so hard
even though they seem to be getting
completely overpowered
at every turn sasuke gets hit right into
the ground
and he looks like yamcha which is never
good
someone of soft k's caliber getting
yamcha
is just crazy to think about but it is
pretty much what's happening here
naruto straight up tells borto to run or
he'll get killed however boruto has
proved himself lately he's no longer
just a pampered spoiled brat
the dude is willing to stand up and
fight as a ninja he's willing to give up
his life and he's not going anywhere my
respect has definitely grown for boruto
as the series went on
and i'm sure it will continue to do so
ishiki straight up points out boruto's
significance
he never thought berto would impede him
he points out that he could teleport
back to the village
but boruto would just follow him and he
doesn't want any more interference so he
just goes with the flow but it stands
that borto is not getting in the way
he's actually been saving naruto and
sasuke and the significance
of that should not be overlooked he's a
player in the game now not a nuisance
and that was inevitable since the series
is called boruto
but i'm glad to see it happening more
and more ishiki then says that if both
the hokage and uchiha die
then maybe the village will reveal
kawaki's location
and the scary thing is this dude clearly
has the power to kill sasuke naruto
and now he's verbalized his intention to
do so
he's not trying to seal them away or
anything so the stakes just definitely
jumped up
all naruto can say is that they won't go
down that easily
the dude can't even say he's gonna win
at this point
which again does not bode well for this
fight and its conclusion
in the middle of this intense fight we
jump to kawaki ishiki speaking to kawaki
in his head in a sort of dream
tells him that kawaki hates his empty
self more than
anything that he has nothing and that
he's empty there's a hole
in his heart and nothing he ever gains
can fill it
then he says that the karma is the thing
the only thing that can fill his broken
heart
it's a special mark he says of course
now kawaki doesn't even have that
and i think this is one of the most
important moments in this chapter hands
down
i feel like a lot of people can relate
to feeling this way at least at some
point in their lives
not seeing the significance of anything
feeling worthless
empty and like nothing you get and
accomplish can change that
it is during these low moments that
people are at their most vulnerable that
they might be willing
to make a deal with the devil himself if
they think it will help make the pain or
meaninglessness
go away and that's exactly the part of
kawaki that ishiki is trying to
manipulate
he emphasizes his feeling of nothingness
and afterwards
he can offer a seeming solution to his
pain and emptiness
this is how people get manipulated and
you can see how that is possible through
kawaki's character
when people are at their lowest and
loneliest they are capable of almost
anything and so we see the seeds of
kawaki falling down the wrong path right
here
rather than trying to fill that hole
with love virtue
and or friendship he might come to feel
that it can only be filled with power
a recurring conflict in the naruto
universe kawaki wakes up and he's in the
byakugan proof hideout
with my boy amado number one cool
scientist
at this point these characters including
kawaki just get caught up on what we
already know
that ishiki showed up and that boruto
was partaking in the fight
and that he used the notsutsuki
technique to get them away from the
village
kawaki is also surprised to see that his
karma is gone
and amado once again explains that the
karma is an otsutsuki backup program
and that kawakis got deleted because
ishiki fully resurrected
in jigen's body interestingly enough
shikamaru says that now kaki is free as
a bird
but he definitely doesn't seem happy
about that he says that ishiki is gonna
try to implant another karma into him
so he is not really as free as a bird
besides it doesn't help being free as a
bird if you're stuck in a cage
like they are right now and although
shikamaru says
let's not lose hope kawaki points out
what we all know
that they're fighting a monster that no
one can defeat at least not right now
amado cool as ever tells him that the
god of death has his
eye on this monster and that he'll die
within a few days if he doesn't succeed
in finding kawaki
by then or finding another vessel and
the motto says even a monster can't
escape death
which is a pretty awesome quote right
there then we jump back to the epic
fight
sasuke's chidori failed and now naruto
tries turasengan
another fan favorite move and naruto's
favorite way to solve problems
but ishiki simply makes them disappear
with his powers
using kurama's chakra naruto reaches for
ishiki with giant arms
and begins launching punches and borto
gets excited
but no sooner does he get excited then
ishiki
appears behind naruto and knees him
right in the back
naruto uses clones and tries the best he
can to catch ishiki while sasuke goes in
for the chidori
teamwork between naruto and sasuke is
always nice to see
but then ishiki drops giant black cubes
from the sky
all of naruto's clones disappear and our
guys manage to survive
but also lose sight of ishiki we went
from ishiki potentially being in trouble
to escaping it and his opponents being
confused
he continues to use the giant black
cubes to attack and to confuse
and then goes after sasuke himself who
blocks ishiki's black rod with his sword
ishiki lets him know that he'll kill
them all one step at a time
and that sasuke is first and then we get
a pretty hilarious moment which made me
laugh
out loud he shrinks sasuke's sword so
that it looks like he took it off an
action figure and then bam he hit sasuke
right in the face with his rod
and returned sasuke's sword to normal
size preparing to finish off sasuke with
it
it seems like it's all over everyone's
been predicting sasuke's possible death
and now ishiki is holding a sword over
his powerless body
and saying this is the end we see boruto
running
but then we jump scenes and here the
title comes into play
this other group including kawaki no
boruto went to fight ishiki
and most think he'll be killed and he
doesn't stand a chance
amado the calmest of all agrees that at
his base strength that's true
but he also says that he thinks borto
has become aware
of what his potential value against
ishiki is
everyone is confused even japanese chess
master shikamatu we jump back to boruto
who jumps in front of ishiki's blade and
single-handedly
saves sasuke from death that must be a
pretty epic moment for any student when
he gets to save his mentor
he also calls sasuke uncle sasuke which
is pretty adorable not gonna lie
ishiki then asks boruto if he wants to
die that badly
but boruto flips it on him again he's
getting to ishiki in a way
sasuke and even naruto are not boruto
points out that he could have killed
both of them
but he didn't boruto comes to the
conclusion that ishiki can't kill him
and ishiki's reaction suggests that this
is true
even sasuke is like nani which by the
way means what
for the non-japanese speakers out there
again we have boruto
acting first and hoping for the best
it's a huge gamble but his action paid
off
and he saved sasuke and now we seem to
have something we can use
for some reason ishiki can't kill boruto
we jump to a motto who says that borto
has guts
and he clearly illustrated in this
chapter that he does
amado also adds that boruto may be the
one holding the key to winning this
battle
and that's the end of the chapter again
boruto is no longer dead weight
without him it seemed like sasuke would
straight up be dead right now
and since sasuke and naruto couldn't do
anything on their own it seems like this
potential value boruto is bringing to
the table
is their best shot not only is burton
unlocking new power
but for some reason ishiki can't kill
him whether it is because he can't kill
motusuki vessel or momoshiki
specifically
remains to be seen perhaps if he tries
borto will automatically tap
into more osuzuki power let me know what
you think about this
in the comments but i for one am
extremely excited to see where this goes
this not only gives our dudes a bit of a
fighting chance it also explains why
boruto might be able to escape death
during this fight as we know he does
because of the time skip
but yeah we are definitely at the point
now where boruto is becoming a relevant
fighter
if not more relevant than even naruto
and sasuke
and that's pretty crazy to think about
and it's pretty hype as well
i can't wait for the next chapter to see
more of this epic fight and also to
learn more
about why exactly boruto is unkillable
to ishiki
and of course i look forward to more
cool amado moments
who is the only dude that never seems
shocked about anything that happens and
seems to know everything ahead of time
and that is it for this one thanks again
for all of your support on these naruto
and boruto videos
if you like this one and want to keep
them coming the best thing to do is
smash that like button and share this
video with any cultured ninja that you
know
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select all or you will miss
future boruto and naruto videos
and while you wait for the next chapter
to drop feel free to check out my
growing naruto playlist
where you'll find videos about the
hokage uzumaki clan otsutsuki clan and
much
much more link in the description and
you can also find me on my brand new
podcast
called the dragon ball virgin which is
now available on spotify apple podcasts
and wherever else you listen to podcasts
i'll also put a link to that in the
description i also want to thank all of
you because the channel has been growing
faster than ever and it's unreal
we passed 980 000 subscribers and
are actually approaching 1 million
subscribers and it's all thanks to you
guys
and i especially want to thank the
patron squad over on patreon and here on
youtube who help make videos like this
one possible
between patreon and the youtube join
function we have over 100 patrons right
now
which is just mind-blowing and amazing
first and foremost i want to thank the
patrons of legend
the ones acknowledged by lord tuigo
himself alpha sigma and liam thompson
and are the one tier patrons the ones
who stand atop all clans
ingrata the world acquire respect pate
heffa jonathan king rathu and aura
emperor otaku thomas
jones ken mano admirath and christopher
torley and our pro hero tier patrons the
one and only gilgamesh who's currently
the most donated overall champion of the
world
nothing but a fan kings eldris anatoly
kazowski angel cruz
cricket xp joe stanton very gucci alicia
actor hinokamian water bonnie parks
jason wilson floreon
joanne garcia steelers mick sheamus
jessica kayla fond
deadly saint and stern hawkins once
again thank you all so much
if you enjoy our work you can support
more of it by going over to patreon.com
animeapro and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these amazing people right here
and you'll even get access to our
private patron only discord
where we talk about anime life and of
course thank memes so check out
patreon.com
animeoutpro link in the description if
you're interested you can also join the
youtube channel
and a lot of you have been doing that by
clicking that blue join button next to
the subscribe button
that you've hopefully already destroyed
so yeah you can support more content
that way if you prefer
whichever way you choose to support us
you will get the same great benefits
thanks again and until next time see us
space cowboys
[Music]
you